- She just announced
a run of summer festival dates,
including New York's
SummerStage, in support of her
critically-acclaimed
album "Home Video."
Here to perform her new song
"Kissing Lessons,"
please welcome back
to the show -- Lucy Dacus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Rachel was a year older ♪
♪ When I was in
the second grade ♪
♪ I thought she might
know everything ♪
♪ I took her word
like a golden ring ♪
♪ I asked her how
to win my man ♪
♪ And she said,
"I know just the thing" ♪
♪ Gave me lip gloss
and a hair toss ♪
♪ And after school,
a lesson in kissing ♪
♪ She called me by the name
of a crush ♪
♪ I couldn't decide
if she was Cole or Justin ♪
♪ I think I called her baby
or darling most the time ♪
♪♪
♪ We'd take turns
being seduced ♪
♪ Imagining the day
it would come into use ♪
we'd start breaking hearts ♪
♪ And taking names ♪
♪♪
♪ She wanted
a three-story house ♪
♪ I wanted to live
by a body of water ♪
♪ With my children
and their father ♪
♪ Children and their father ♪
♪ Three sons and a beautiful
daughter ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪♪
♪ Rachel's family moved
out of town ♪
♪ I don't remember
when we stopped hanging out ♪
♪ But I still wear a letter R
charm on my bracelet ♪
♪ And wonder if she thinks
of me as her first kiss ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]